i'm loyal to the empire yes
but will the empire be loyal to you
it hasn't always shown benevolence to
your kind
you're becoming sentimental
hey guys pete here today i thought i'd
do a quick video about foundation if you
haven't heard it was announced that
there will be a season two it's been
renewed by apple tv plus and a few days
ago showrunner david s goyer did an ama
on reddit where he gave some more
details about that and answered a lot of
fan questions about the first season so
today i'm just gonna go through some of
the more interesting things i picked up
from that and as far as spoilers for
this video he was pretty careful not to
give away future plot points there are
some references to character names and
different things but i won't be going
into any great detail to explain what
that means for the big picture and with
that out of the way let's get into it
about two weeks ago both deadline and
variety published nearly identical
stories saying that foundation had been
renewed for season 2 by apple i'll put
links to the articles in the description
if you want to check them out for
yourself but it looks like they were
working with the same press release
there's a statement from apple tv's head
of programming saying that they're happy
with the way things are going and
they're happy to make more david s goyer
talks about how he always wanted to
bring this story to life and isaac
asimov's daughter robin who's an
executive producer on the show talks
about her feelings and what she thinks
her father would have thought about the
adaptation she says david goyer's
foundation has surpassed all my
expectations by bringing my father's
philosophy and ideas to the screen in
ways he could never do while staying
true to his work i know my father would
have been proud to see his iconic story
come to life through the show's visual
beauty and the layered characters
understanding full well his words would
need this cinematic translation my
father was deeply indebted to his fans
to their loyalty and always hoped his
work would pass through to following
generations that they're renewing it is
the only thing that they're saying at
this time there's no details about when
we should expect to see more episodes
when they're gonna start filming or
anything along those lines in the ama
when he was asked about it he said that
they have a vague release schedule but
because of the uncertainties of kobit we
would never announce a release date
until a given season had finished
filming he had several questions asking
if they thought they could improve
things and he said yes i would love to
improve on a host of things and i think
you will see with season two that we
already have the first thing we did from
soup to nuts is say what can we improve
on and when asked about hints he says
hobermallow bel rios a strong general
and a weak emperor and the church of the
galactic spirit he mentioned the
characters hobermallow and general bel
rios in the articles and we also heard
gail mention those names in the opening
of the first episode as far as the
timeline and how much of the story
they're telling before the show ever
came out he pitched it as an eight
season plan and they talked about how
this was a story that was a thousand
years long this brought up some
questions for people who had read the
series because the timeline in the books
only makes it about 500 years past the
beginning of the foundation of course
the setup is that establishing the
foundation will shorten the inner regnum
that 30 000 years of barbarism that was
supposed to come after the empire falls
their plan is supposed to shorten that
time frame down to a thousand years
until a new empire can take its place so
when he was asked about the show's
timeline he said that if we're able to
do the full eight season plan we will
eventually progress beyond the 500 plus
fe that azimov got to in his novels that
was always anticipated with the asimov
estate so 500 plus fe relates to the
timeline the first year of the
foundation became year number one fe and
the stories he wrote went about 500
years beyond that
some fans brought up questions about
what books they're actually adapting
what they had rights to goyer's answer
was we have rights to all the foundation
books just not the others and here when
he says the others he's talking about
the empire series and the robot series
asimov connected those all together at
the end but they're not bundled as the
same intellectual property this was a
question if they had rights to all the
foundation books rather than just the
trilogy and since they're connected
would that also include concepts from
the robot series as you've seen with
demarzo on the show robots have a long
life span compared to humans so this
character is present in both series and
takes on different names at different
points of the story goyer used this to
explain some of the rights issues
between the series saying our danielle
oliva is part of the irobot's rights
which skydance
apple do not have access to we have
access to the demerseal side of the
character if that makes sense so there's
a shared history which it sounds like
the show can draw from but they just
can't use the name this confirmed who
the character was since some book
readers were questioning that but it
also brought up some questions about
things we've seen happen in relation to
the laws of robotics he said that
asimov's robotics laws do exist in the
universe of the show but that doesn't
necessarily mean that demarzel is
presently bound by them and to explain
further would spoil far too much so a
user named argentis asked this question
how do you have rights to the laws of
robotics but not demarzel's book
identity they seem congruent he said we
were given a clear dictate as to what
rights we have access to what rights are
shared and which ones are off limits so
just to bring all that together they do
have the rights to adapt all seven books
in the foundation series the two
prequels where asimov went back and gave
harry selden a backstory fleshed out
some of the details about how he put
psycho history together on trantor the
original trilogy and the two books that
came after that where asimov was trying
to bring the story to an end he never
actually did that though the final book
foundation and earth doesn't have a
definitive ending the story in the book
ends but to say it in a spoiler-free way
there are a lot of questions about how
things will proceed from there that
brings things back to him saying that
they would go beyond the 500 plus years
in the books and the idea of a thousand
year tale he touched on that saying gaia
slash galaxia is a possibility but i
also have inside info on how asimov was
thinking of ending the thing so if we
get there we'll be exploring that just
to be clear asimov planned on writing
another book beyond foundation and earth
he was having trouble working it all out
and that's when he decided to add the
prequels and then he died not long after
he finished writing them the implication
here is that the show is setting out to
complete the story if and it's a big if
in today's television climate they get
to make eight seasons in relation to
changes they made for the adaptation he
pointed out it was a remix of the story
and said season one loosely adapts
stories from the first book while
weaving in some characters and concepts
from the prequels for those who read the
books as surmised the number of the
show's characters are composite
characters gale is a combo of two
characters the other of which book
readers may well guess cleon the 14th
also has elements of leopold the first
etc and about the characterization of
salvor hardin which there were a lot of
questions about he said our salvor is
not the fully formed salver of the books
this is her origin story we're picking
her up a good 20 years before the salvor
that appears in the encyclopedist she
hasn't yet internalized the teachings of
her father etc he also addressed the fan
sentiment that they were misinterpreting
the character and what the overall story
was about because there were chosen one
vibes with gail and salvor his response
to that was i will say salvor is not a
mary sue or a chosen one people are
making certain assumptions which i
understand see where the story goes in a
different answer he continued there
aren't any chosen ones in the show but
we play with the concept of people
feeling like they might be and other
people believing they might be so make
what you will of that
some other things he mentioned were that
they had to be careful not to resemble
other sci-fi series like star wars and
dune which is kind of funny considering
that those works were originally
influenced by foundation he said that in
the show's universe regular human minds
can't tolerate the space-time
displacement on the jump ships and we'll
learn more about that as things progress
and there were a lot of people dragging
him about the anacrion attack in episode
five and to that he said look here's the
truth originally we had a lot more time
scheduled for that scene and a lot more
extras planned but because of kovid we
were only allowed 60 extras in a day and
a half to film that scene we planned a
lot more gun hits stunt falls etc but
kova just made it impossible and one
final question came from the user
mysterious asparagus who asked if we
would see selden's younger days at some
point goyer answered yes and then he
added even back to early childhood it
delivered some answers but as the show
often does it also brought up some more
questions the idea of composite
characters is something that you would
notice if you read the whole series and
i thought it was a little bit weird that
he said gail was specifically two
characters because it feels like it's
more than that but i don't think i'll
get into all that right now this seems
like a pretty good place to leave things
let me know what you think about his
answers what you think about season two
please like this video if you enjoyed it
please subscribe to my channel if you
haven't already and thanks for watching
i'll talk to you soon